the Berlin International Film Festival
wrapped up this weekend but not without
some controversy Chinese filmmaker
Johnny mo you may know him from films
such as hero and he also produced the
opening and closing ceremonies at the
2008 Beijing Olympics well he withdrew
his film one second from the event and
according to reports it had to do with
Chinese censors the film is set during
China's brutal Cultural Revolution
period back in 2017 Beijing passed new
laws regulating its film industry
stating that movies must quote serve the
people and socialism it also said that
any film submitted to an overseas film
festival would require official approval
Chinese artist Ai Weiwei also says he's
been targeted by Beijing's film censors
it relates to the cities of love film
anthology he was invited to direct one
of the episodes in the New Berlin I love
you but he found out that his
contribution was cut this is part of his
statement quote it was infuriating to
find our involvement had been erased
the reason we were given for the
episodes removal was that my political
status had made it difficult for the
production team to secure further
funding i Weiwei spoke to DW about these
allegations and in an exclusive also
told us about why the film was not
considered for the Berlin Film Festival
he hardly needs an introduction i Weiwei
is one of China's most well known
contemporary artists I want to start
straightaway by asking you about
censorship in China for creatives has
the situation gotten worse it sounds
like you've got recent news I think as a
situation getting worse and but the
policy is always the same the purpose is
to censor every art or literature or
film and make sure that I will not go
different from party line and in terms
of your own situation Berlin I love you
is a film that you have been involved
with it sounds like you've hit some
problems there tell me more
yes I read recently I learned that this
film bullying I love you
and has vetro my
episode I'm the first one directory
involved and they're being invited to do
this film I direct the films when I was
in China I still under a soft detention
and did it through Facebook actually
first time not Facebook but my son also
played a role in the film so that film
has been I using as promoting for the
film bullying I love you but recently I
found out my name is not on the list
so I asked the producer and director
they gave me the answers quite
surprising they told me they submitted
this filmed Pauline Film Festival then
the festival tell them if I were ways in
there as the film cannot never be
accepted also they told me because they
are involved to maker Shanghai I love
you under the producer in there also
sink to put my episode in their film
would damage their possibilities can we
talk a little bit about China's impact
on artists because this is happening in
Berlin right it's not happening
domestically in China anymore I think is
a very important point
China happy has become much more
powerful and a globally plays a major
role in politics and economics but at
the same time China start promoting is a
so-called soft power that means China
has been very effectively used their own
ideology to to to apply in you West
University's scientific lab trees and
now in you can clearly see in the
entertainment and in this kind of
industry so what happens in the top
industries offer festivals I think they
all under Chinese inference under the
censorship is there and I think the West
collapse this
can you censorship in the sense okay
last question which is what is the way
forward in terms of your role that was
cut your film that was cut in Berlin I
love you and then on a grander scale
what is the way forward for Chinese
creatives who want to be free who want
to freely express themselves I think is
send a very strong message and about a
very very dark one because young people
who never even imagine they can pass
this can the hearts and censorship if
you are a film maker it's very hard for
you to get permission to film in China
and you film if someone like Tony Moore
can face in this can problem if someone
like me can be facing this kind of
dramatic situation so think about a
young artist and so China would not have
just lost the ability for free freedom
of expression but they were lost whole
generations imagination courage and
their passion part way way it's very
good to see you after all these years
thank you